Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
Today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians, good morning!
Good morning!
Thank you for joining us today for our 57th episode!
BAU BAU!
I can't believe it's the 57th.
I thought it was the 56th episode today.
You were very confused.
And Moco-chan was like, no.
No, it's 57!
The other day was 56!
Yeah.
It goes too fast, Ruffians.
Well, for any Ruffians joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
It's a good day, Ruffians!
A great day!
End of the week!
End of the week, a sign of a very fun weekend!
Well, did we have any Ruffians but Peron?
Let's see!
De-den!
What?
Is Pero okay?
This is amazing!
What?
Pero successfully climbed Mount Everest?
Is this a vacation?
Is he going to be okay with the cold temperatures and the elevations?
Actually, maybe it's not so much of a vacation.
Cause you know, I heard that it's not really that amazing of a feat anymore, you know?
There's so many people doing it now, that it's actually really warm up there!
It looks pretty cold, but... I don't know... Ruffians, do you think you would want to climb Mount Everest one day maybe?
Actually, I'm kind of surprised that Pero would want to do something like this.
Let me say that he didn't get, like, kidnapped, go up to the mountains or something, you know?
Kidnapped up to the mountains?
Does that happen?
Getting kidnapped all the way to the top of Mount Everest?
I don't know.
I don't think so.
I don't know, but... Unlikely.
Maybe it's chill, but... There's no Wi-Fi up there, but you know.
Hell great getting Wi-Fi, so... I don't know, maybe that's why they wanted him.
That's a volcano, not a mountain.
Mococo are Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Hopefully Pero can find his way down, but... I don't know, I like the silly faces making.
It's very satisfying.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians!
There was some details shared about something really exciting coming up.
FUWAMOCO!
We're gonna be part of hololive's end of the year show, Yukuhoro Kuruhoro!
And us!
FUWAMOCO, that's us!
We're gonna be part of the big clip show, the Toritaka!
It's big!
It's the end of the year, you know!
BAU BAU!
Congratulations!
Thank you!
I'm really looking forward to it!
Ruffians, you know you can actually submit your favorite clips from the whole entire year as part of the listener submitted category using the YouTube clip function and then sharing them on Twitter with the Toretaka Taiso hashtag.
So, if you're interested, please try it out, okay?
We'll do our best as members of Advent and hololive English!
BAU BAU!
Please do it!
Okay, there's too many to count, I know.
I know.
If you have one that really sticks out in your mind... Is there anything that stands out right now, Ruffians?
Give me some FUWAMOCO moments.
Advent moments.
Please say goodbye, okay?
Bye bye!
Amazing skills.
Wow, you know what?
There's been some other exciting things too.
Actually, there was a birthday.
There was!
There was Oboe-senpai's birthday!
And actually, we are invited to sing together with her!
We sang a song called Baby Sleeper.
Yeah!
You know, we're really happy to be able to sing with Hubo-senpai!
But also able to sing a song that we really, really like, too!
Thank you, sweet Cherry!
I mean, Hubo-senpai.
She gets us.
She gets us, yeah, you know.
Actually, she shared her new original song, Enta, together with all of us, too!
Yeah, it's part of the new music label, together with hololive and Universal Music Japan, called HoloEN.
Please check it out, Ruffians, if you haven't.
Okay!
I really like Kobo-senpai's music.
It has a very... Kobo-senpai's sound to it is very different from others.
That sounds like an excuse!
It's not an excuse!
But I understand what you mean.
It feels very, like...
Kobo-senpai.
Maroyaka.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Smooth.
Smooth!
Sort of like water.
Yeah, a nice cup of warm water.
BAU BAU!
Happy birthday, Kobo-senpai!
While continuing the music news, actually we had some more senpai release a new original song.
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Mococo Abyssgard!
I think they do.
Yeah, that is really good.
Only the coolest songs, right?
Yeah, right!
And you know the music video's amazing, too!
Yeah!
All fully 3D and everything!
Everything!
Fire and ice.
I know.
We're really happy that we have this original song together now, too.
Yeah, you know, I feel like everybody's been waiting for such a long time for something like this.
Right, right.
Why did it take this long, huh?
Huh?
I have a complaint.
What?
Well, now it's here!
It's here!
Not... It's not here today.
It is here today.
But it was here as in Akari-senpai's channel, not on the FUWAMOCO channel.
That wouldn't make sense.
It's here.
Yesterday!
Yesterday, yesterday.
Please check it out, okay?
Yeah, it's a really cool song.
BAU BAU!
It's cool.
And hot.
Fire and ice.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, you know FUWAMOCO Morning is not just about sharing music news, you know.
Oh, well, it's exciting.
Yeah, that's a lot of music.
We do have Pero Sightings, too, but actually, it seems like there have been a lot of FUWAMOCO Sightings around the world recently.
And not just Pero Sightings.
Not just Pero Sightings.
We got reports actually that FUWAMOCO, we are spotted cheering on a wrestling match!
Look at us there on the side!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
You know, BAU BAU means a lot of different things, you know, depending on the situation.
But in this situation, what does it mean?
BAU BAU is... Smash the opponent!
Flip them over and grab their arm like that.
Yeah, that's what it means.
I don't know what it's called.
What's a wrestling move, Moco-chan?
Lariat.
Lariat!
What's the thing where you hold their head and you're like BAU BAU BAU BAU?
Head crunch.
Head lock!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
What's wrong, Moco-chan?
If you're not careful, I'm gonna headlock you.
Is that all you have to say?
I'll do a lyre.
Yeah!
It's pretty cool.
You know, hopefully there, the wrestling skills transfer to us for a big fight that we couldn't have one day.
Right, Ruffians?
You know, we have the extreme violence.
Yeah, extreme violence.
Ah, FUWAMOCO wrestling when?
One day.
It's part of our goals, right?
A suplex.
We'll have to do all the training.
We'll have to train.
But also!
Not just wrestling.
There was a very cute Moco-chan cosplay spotted on TV in the Philippines too!
BAU BAU!
It makes me feel a bit like a...
Dinosaur.
Dinosaur?
You're gonna say superstar.
Superstar!
A superstar dinosaur.
Oh, even better.
We're doing our all so that maybe one day we can come visit you in your country someday too.
At least we're doing our best right now.
You know, next week we won't be in the Philippines, but... Go make a fiesta!
We can come visit you in your country someday too!
At least, we're doing our best, right?
You know, next week we won't be in the Philippines, but... Go to Malaysia!
Malaysia!
Maybe!
Maybe one day, Ruffians, you can come visit us!
Please do again!
BAU BAU!
So happy.
I wonder when I'll be able to make my Philippine TV debut too.
You can wait.
Maybe next time, ha?
Maybe next time.
Ruffians!
It's been a little while since you know we had a confession for you.
But, well... You have something you have to say, huh?
Yeah, I have something that I should share, you know?
You should!
You see, you know, Ruffians, as you know, we really like seeing your thoughts and your tweets on Twitter, right?
Yeah, yeah!
Is that a confession?
Basically, you know, FUWAMOCO has been even more crazy than it's usually been for us.
I don't think, Ruffians, I don't think you really know, and that's okay.
That's okay, but we've just been doing our best, you know.
But actually, I was taking a look at some of your tweets while I was in bed, before I fell asleep.
What happened?
You know, I started to drift off and accidentally... I liked a few of your tweets.
But it was okay!
You know, because when I woke up, I realized what I did and I was conscious enough to read your message and I did actually really like it!
So, it was okay.
Half asleep?
Not even half asleep.
It happened...
It was okay, right?
But... Ruffians... The issue is... Is that... This wasn't the first time Fuwawa did something like this, huh?
No.
One time.
Almost added a Twitter profile too.
Yeah.
When I woke up, it was asking me if I wanted to save the changes made to my profile.
That could've been really bad, huh?
Not even a sleep tweet.
In the future though, I'll take measures.
I'll be careful not to look at Twitter too much before bed.
That way we don't accidentally like tweets half asleep.
That would be awful, right, Ruffians?
You wouldn't want us to, like, retweet when we're not awake, okay?
But that just means that you tweet the first thing I see when I wake up, right?
BAU BAU!
When you fall asleep, that's when you wake up.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
It's good to get that off my chest a bit.
You feel better a bit?
Yeah.
It's not gonna happen again now that you confessed it.
I can't promise.
BAU Moco-chan.
Ruffians!
Actually, there's something else.
It's not a confession, but
It's a bit of a concern.
You know.
It's the holiday season, right?
Right?
Right!
Yeah, and Ruffians, that means Christmas is almost here, right?
Christmas means Ruffians.
What does it mean to you?
Yeah.
What is Christmas to you?
Holidays to you?
I could say, you know, Christmas is... Yummy food!
Reindeer!
What about... What about... Miniskirt Santas?
Hi.
That's, that's an important part of the holiday landscape, right?
Right!
And the other day, Ruffians, you know when we were playing White Album, right?
Toya was all talking about imagining Yuki in a Santa costume and how cute she would be!
And then, uh, suddenly he imagined her so hard that we could see her too!
Yeah.
Well, Ruffians!
Have you not been imagining?
It doesn't really seem like it.
I haven't really seen any FUWAMOCO festive pictures or anything.
Are you glad that Toya beat you?
Or is it that you don't think that we suit being Santa or bringing cheer and happiness to all the good Ruffians everywhere all across the world?
What do you say, Ruffians?
I see!
That's all.
That's it.
I mean, Santa has a bigger tummy than Moco-chan.
Fluffy and fuzzy, but not fluffy and fuzzy enough to have a beard, you know?
Please don't imagine me with a big tummy, please!
Yeah, but...
You know, if you cut out little holes in the hat, then our ears will fit too, so... We could be Santa if we wanted to, right?
No?
Well, let's do our best not to think too hard about it, Moco-chan, okay?
It's concerning, though.
Well, no, it's not concerning.
A cute Doggie of the Day!
Let's go check out who the Doggie of the Day is today.
Today we have... De-den!
Bucky!
Bucky's the Doggie of the Day!
Bucky sure looks festive.
Very happy, yeah.
Bucky's freshly bathed and cleaned up on his way back from the groomers.
Fancy, huh?
However, this Ruffian says
He's ready to get himself dirty all over again.
Bucky.
Hi.
What about just saying nice and clean and fluffy and fuzzy hi?
Right, that's good but...
Apparently not.
But also, Bucky's tongue is a little bit big for his head and usually it's sticking out like this!
It's super cute!
We love it, Bucky.
It could be dangerous though.
Don't get it stuck anywhere, okay?
No, yeah.
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO-chan, how does Bucky BAU BAU?
My tongue is normal size so
Pretend that it's really long.
BAU BAU!
Like that.
Like that, yeah.
It's so cute.
But, you know, Bucky Bucky's a silly little cotton puff with a big tongue and lots of love to share.
And I'm sure he really loves how much you spoil him, but he also loves to have fun and a part of that fun is getting dirty again too.
Don't mind it too much, okay?
BAU BAU!
And for today's walk we have De-den!
That's so cool!
That's so impressive!
You know, like, spiders are scary and everything, but seeing the webs like this is the best.
Right!
Very, very impressive.
Thank you for sharing that with us!
Actually, you know, whenever we come across a very impressive spider web like this, we also actually...
Take a photo too.
You can't just let it be, right?
You have to get a photo.
Right.
Take it from all different angles and everything too.
But you know, I think we have to say that yours is definitely the best of best.
It's very mesmerizing.
Yeah, well, hopefully you're able to free up your mirror before you started driving because I don't think you need that when you're driving.
You can just see the mirror, right?
Probably.
Probably for the best.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
We also received a Question of the Day today.
We have De-den!
I was wondering, after your first mini Rock n' Rawr Party, how did it feel to hear the Ruffians cheering in person instead of reading the praise?
Also, did you do any extra preparation beforehand compared to a normal Rock n' Rawr Party?
It was very very different!
It's too bad we can't hear your voices regularly, huh?
But you know, as for prep though, it's not really that different.
You know, we just thought, what songs that maybe those Ruffians might want to hear there, and you know, what we want to share and say with you to them.
You know, that sort of thing.
You know, we want to have as much fun with you as possible!
So we think about a lot of things when preparing for a rock n' rawr party, you know?
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your questions, your Doggie of the Day, your Pero Sightings, your scoops too.
Thank you so much for always being part of us, Ruffians.
BAU BAU!
Don't forget.
Oh, use the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
As for our next team, we have... Maybe something that some of you are looking forward to.
We have... De-den!
We're gonna be in the best of company playing lethal company together with Nerissa and Biboo!
BAU!
BAU BAU!
Best of Christmas songs during our Rock n' Rawr Party!
And this will be our second un-archive, so you can only catch it then, okay, Ruffians?
We hope that you'll be there live to sing along with us and be BAU-ry BAU-ry.
It's gonna be a silly time for sure.
It's gonna be a bit silly.
Please get your Santa hats ready too, okay, Ruffians?
Lights and everything.
Can't forget the palm lights.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for joining us today, Ruffians!
Wow, this week ended all of a sudden, but really all of a sudden, huh?
It's been really fun.
Thank you, Ruffians!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Echo Tutu!
BAU BAU!
Joints!
Legs!
BAU BAU!
Global!
Gamales!
BAU BAU!
Baldy!
Scoochie!
BAU BAU!
Vincenzo!
Moritake!
BAU BAU!
Voxus!
Apocyrus!
BAU BAU!
And every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!